Nice, Fernando!
Nice, that's it, that's the idea, that's the idea, get in there!
Next grid there!
Rob, that's you, you gotta get somebody there with you, yeah?
Switch, next grid, next grid!
Next grid, who's here, who's here, who's here, who's here?
Yeah, call somebody, call somebody, you're alone, you're alone, you're alone.
That's it, next grid, next grid, you guys are in, next grid, turn, turn, you're on offense!
Call one with you, Grayson, call somebody with you, Grayson.
Nice, Frank, next grid, next grid!
Grayson, call one, call one, Grayson!
Nice, nice, shift, shift, shift!
Nice, good chat, boys, good chat, good chat!
Nice, Grayson, nice!
That's it, watch this next grid!
Who's on D, who's on D?
That's it, great job, Joe!
Great hands, Marlon!
That's it, boys, that's it, find the gap, nice!
Earlier, Jake, that's it, that's it, that's it, shift in!
One more on D, one more on D!
Move, move, move, move, move!
Turn it, turn it!
Oh!
Get on your left!
Shift, shift, shift, you're in the next grid, you're in the next grid!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!